[Musique]
aujourd'hui les amis nous allons piéger
un chat et oui vous avez très bien
entendu toutes les caméras sont en place
je sens qu'on va se fendre la poire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti voyons voir si félix se rend
compte du subterfuge
regardez les mecs je crois qu'il se
dirige vers sa gamelle
et oui les amis nous avons au préalable
changer les croquettes de félix félix
est un très grand fan des croquettes au
goût saumon battent ils se rendent
compte que celles ci ont été remplacés
par des croquettes groupe où les boeufs
[Musique]
il est en train de les manger et oui ce
n'est pas gagné les amis félix peut
encore se rendre compte que ce ne sont
pas ces croquettes au mieux s'en est pas
rendu compte que dalle les a carrément
avaler les amis si vous aimez le risque
je vous conseille de vous cramponner
pour ce qui va suivre
voici cimbal le colocataire de félix
voyons maintenant jusqu'où nous pouvons
piéger félix tu maintenant la style
ouais les mecs je viens de mettre en
position
il est tellement obligé de te prendre
pour simbad tu devrais penser à une
reconversion si jamais tu n'as pas
perdre ton job de nikon et jeff c'est
plus le moment attention
félix se rapproche il est en train de le
fixe est dangereusement là
ne bouge surtout pas de steen ne bouge
surtout pas
[Musique]
tente de clés chez la pâte les charges
sont souvent ça en effet jeff a raison
les félins de type ch à utiliser leur
langue pour se toiletter voyons voir si
ça va marcher
[Musique]
à marcher c'était incroyable
bien joué mais le stress parce qu'il me
regarde et carrément dans les yeux comme
quoi y'a pas que les chats qui retombent
toujours sur leurs pattes
c'est une mission accomplie pour la team
fou
encore une fois tout le monde n'y a vu
que du feu
huit créations j'ai comme l'impression
que vous avez pris votre pied alors
abonnez vous et rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour des caméras cachées
encore plus fun top hendrix
[Musique]